gigi hadid fires back after receiving
major backlash over an Instagram post
she wrote about Greece
okay let's rewind Gigi was just on
vacation the Greek island Mykonos and
had unless than awesome time because the
villa she was staying in got robbed Gigi
did what all gen Z people do when they
have a bone to pick she took to social
media to air her grievances the
supermodel shared this pick on her
secondary Instagram account writing PSA
don't let insta fool you got robbed
never going back LOL wouldnt recommend
spend your money elsewhere while that
post landed Gigi in some hot water one
user wrote quote let me get this
straight
you're blaming in the whole of Mykonos
because you were robbed and in
retaliation you're trying to impact
their tourism and economy by telling
people not to go there and all of this
is done with a bikini pic okay girl
and many people pointed out that you can
get robbed literally anywhere one user
explained quote I got robbed in Miami I
don't tell people not to go there stupid
post lots of commenters also pointed out
that Greece's economy relies heavily on
tourism and that Gigi's post could do
some serious damage to the country well
on Tuesday Gigi responded to the
backlash in the comments section of the
controversial post quote let me make
this clear for everyone below who thinks
I don't deserve to have an opinion on my
experience and warn people of this I was
robbed along with more than 30 houses
that night some to gunpoint
Gigi added that she wasn't able to
contact any form of law enforcement
except through her local security who
happened to have a contact something she
says is a quote privilege that most
travelers wouldn't have Gigi continued
quote this is not information that is
shared with people before they go if I'd
known it happened so much and there was
not enough infrastructure to protect
myself I wouldn't have gone so this is
my opinion based on actual events and
you not liking that isn't my problem and
for all the haters who criticize the 24
year old for posting pics from the trip
after telling her fans
not to visit the country well she had
this to say I work my ass off and never
do a trip like this for myself and
friends so if I want to post pictures of
the trip after being robbed I will do so
you have to treat yourself thankfully
Gigi has something more positive to
focus on back home her budding romance
with Bachelorette runner-up Tyler
Cameron she's been spotted on multiple
dates with the aspiring model it's not
the worst night out still a source tells
e.t quote although Gigi and Tyler are
spending more and more time together
they are still casually dating I mean
honestly it's everything I could ever
ask for the two have good cause to take
things slowly since they both recently
got out of serious dating situations
Gigi went through a breakup from a
serious relationship and Tyler just got
off a dating show the two are enjoying
building a friendship first going on
dates and having fun nothing more than
that right now good for you Gigi he is
hot of course I will be here to keep you
up to date on all things Gigi and Tyler
so make sure to keep it locked right
here on ET until next time I'm Holly
Stephens bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]